casa is working with you he trains you
and then all of a sudden you start
fighting at what point did you know that
you could be the heavyweight champion
like hey you got to fight you got two
fights you got three fights
14 years old you know you were gonna
have to be the champion before you
become the champion so that means
lifestyle
after being before you become
you gotta be him before you become him
unpack that
um you have to live his lifestyle the
lifestyle of a champion i'm the champion
you look at the champion
that's how it starts you look at
somebody i want to be like him
you don't say hey i'm a bad [ __ ]
i want to fight anybody out here
nobody's going to kick my ass you see
somebody and say hey i might want to do
that
so inspiration the source of inspiration
so so is that what got you to be uh
willing to be disciplined to get what
you want like to become a champion at 14
years or so i'm willing to have
everything it takes to be a champion
absolutely and then i had cuss over
there telling me why why should he have
it
that's one thing i never had in my life
being because i always got picked on and
i never had jealousy or emptiness about
anything and cuss possessed that
you know and he was telling me why
should he have all that money and you
don't why is he why
why why do you believe that he's better
than you why you think he should have
all that money you don't and he was
really serious about it
and that was the competition [ __ ]
that's it right there breathing that
stuff right in me why why should he have
and he's not better than you
how did you handle that when he told you
that 14.
would it piss you off were you like i'm
going to go train to whoop his ass and
i'm going to get there one day what was
that what was your response to it he
said one day oh god i can't tell you
this guy knew how to really get in my
head he said man you're fighting good
but i wish you were bigger because i
wish you were like
kenny norton uh another another guy mike
mike weaver because they had big bodies
and they could intimidate somebody and
that hurt my feet i said i make sure the
whole world will be afraid of me
he laughed but that's what i said so he
knew how to poke you oh yeah
did it piss you off or you're like i'm
gonna prove you a wrong type of a thing
i better not you know i better act like
i'm upset and mad at him yes sir
i'll do better why if you did what would
happen yes you know you just don't talk
to me you know what i'm telling you
don't talk to him like that's your
teacher are you worried that he may take
time and spend time with somebody else
instead of you or you're just kind of
like i respect the teacher i want to
listen to it i want i want him to be
satisfied with my work i want to say you
look beautiful today
like he said when he first said when he
first said it to me and i thought he was
a weirdo i wanted to say it again
i wanted to say now i don't know he's a
weirdo and i know he's not weird i want
to say he loves me again
how much of what he did to you
do you do to your kids and others listen
i wouldn't dare do to my kids what he
did to me why is that baby
um i could because um
you some some guys listen
this is the real deal
if i don't do well in boxing i go to
prison or i die if my kids don't do well
they go back to a big house and all
their rich friends come over and they
play and eat stuff and get that come on
it's not the same how do you create that
pressure for them how do you create that
can you actually create that kind of
intensity and pressure or no by the time
i'm sending a military school if you got
to pick a sport
so you're going to send them to military
schools
these kids don't want to get tough
enough they may have a heart attack
nowadays
how do you do that though how you
actually do that is is it even possible
in your mind to pass down that toughness
to someone else
well listen you can always be tough but
even though i don't care how much money
you got some guy money got how
successful you are and you may not like
him he did wrong you're never better
than your father
why is that it's just just the way god
made it
it's just the way i don't care how much
money i have how much
my father would kick my ass my father
would kill me
we're not our fathers
go a little deeper with that that's a
pretty deep comment it's just that my
father's a real serious guy
i would never want to have a
qualification with him this is who's
your father this is you're talking about
customs
okay i got you wow so to you you know
even as a champion in the world i have
people my body's got crew i'm still a
little airy of him he was just that kind
of guy he's killed people he's done bad
stuff he was just that kind of guy so
your dad was feared by others he was an
interesting guy he's a preacher
he's a preacher
okay
he's a preacher now no he's always been
in the church he's born in the church
raising church
preacher deacon preacher yeah listen
mean [ __ ]
i mean i bet 100 of people got baptized
i swear to god if you don't get baptized
i'm gonna take you out afterwards was it
like that or oh no listen they don't
play my family the religious the
christian side they don't [ __ ] rap
they're all articulate they're gonna go
to ivies they're very intelligent but
yes they're physical
what's what's your style of parenting
your kids now what's your style of
parenting them
is it okay so give me some of the values
responsibility um listen
sometimes um you're not going to go on
the plane that you're by yourself they
said we're going to go back on a plane
where it's just only us no because you
didn't do really good today
that's just how it is you know sometimes
you gotta know it never fails when you
take something away from somebody that
once they possessed it and fell in love
with it and take it away
i like doing that too you know once you
take something away people um hey they
get on their p's and kids quick right
they do the crying see the crying's not
gonna work
i love you dad
to to to be able to do that it also
takes a little bit of uh knowing that
you got to challenge this person to
improve their character long term hey
listen right i have a night no no i have
a 24 year old son right yeah and every
now and then i see him he tries to
wrestle with me he's bigger than me but
he wrestles with me and i tell him like
get your [ __ ] hands off me
you know i know what's in his mind
i know it's in this mind don't let them
play with me like that
are you joking with them or not
oh you're dancing
i mean i'm sure if if somebody was your
son telling you get your hands off me
they gotta they gotta listen to you well
listen
you listen somebody this listen
for some reason when a young kid
feels that his mother they're not
together they feel even if they're
together he feels that his mother they
they challenge you for their mother love
any kind of way if you're sleeping with
them they want to get in the middle and
their babies the next thing you have an
argument they want a defender and
challenge you it's all about that
connection with them they feel they have
to protect their mother
and i said you can't be mad at that so
you gotta go you gotta pick your battles
that's all so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]